souveraineté ce n'est pas le repli de la
france sur elle même ce n'est pas la
fermeture des frontières ce n'est pas
l'autarcie la souveraineté c'est la
capacité à nourrir son peuple c'est la
capacité à être autonome d'un point de
vue énergétique pour permettre
l'économie c'est la capacité de se
défendre et nous n'avons pas traité de
ce point là et puis la dernière chose
qui est plus récente que peut-être le
général de gaulle n'avait pas imaginé
qui est l'autonomie et la souveraineté
en matière de numérique qui devient un
enjeu stratégique aujourd'hui
non
à la lumière de la crise de l'aco vide
les français ont commencé à comprendre
dans leur vie de tous les jours les
phénomènes très précis de la
souveraineté de la perte de souveraineté
économique au travers d'exemples
emblématique quitter les masques ou
paracétamol la guerre en ukraine à
partir du début de cette année a
accentué cette perception et a réalisé
un vrai choc de conscience auprès des
français notamment avec la souveraineté
alimentaire et la souveraineté
énergétique donc nous avons décidé avec
la commission des affaires économiques
de procéder à un inventaire de toutes
nos fragilités de toutes nos pertes de
souveraineté sur l'ensemble des secteurs
économiques français nous voyons une
perte de souveraineté absolument
généralisé sur tous les grands secteurs
économiques français
par exemple nous avons observé des
pertes de souveraineté alimentaire
aujourd'hui un jour et demi par semaine
nous mangeons des produits qui sont des
produits importés et en particulier des
pays intra européens par exemple en
matière d'énergie les atermoiements dans
les dix dernières années sur l'énergie
nucléaire nous met dans une situation
aujourd'hui extrêmement fragile
d'abord parce que les choix du nucléaire
n'ont pas été clairs ensuite parce que
le financement d'edf n'apparaît été
réalisés et également parce que en
stigmatisant le nucléaire et en mettant
des objectifs qui sont des objectifs de
réduction apparente du nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique eh bien nous
décourageons les talents et nous
décourageons les compétences et ça ça a
des effets délétères à long terme
[Musique]
on
nous avons surtout voulu apporter des
solutions opérationnelles est clair
qu'ils sont des solutions à mettre en
oeuvre immédiatement
je vais vous en prendre peut-être
quelques exemples nous préconisons
effectivement une feuille de route
nucléaire extrêmement ambitieuse
extrêmement clair mais à mettre en
oeuvre très rapidement ou sur d'autres
sujets nous avons des recommandations
l'exemple agricole est un bon exemple
nous ne sommes pas du tout renfermé sur
lui-même nous ne sommes pas contre les
traités de libre échange nous allons les
traiter avec le canada nous avons des
traités le brésil nous avons des traités
avec la nouvelle zélande nous avons des
traités et asie bref à chaque fois on
regarde l'intérêt du traité par rapport
à ce pays là mais pour l'agriculture de
façon transversale avec l'ensemble des
pays nous ne regardons pas les effets et
nous les anticipons pas il ya donc là
une véritable réflexion à mener avec
l'union européenne mais aussi de façon
démocratique dans les parlements de
chaque pays et singulièrement le nôtre
pour dire si on accepte ou si on
n'accepte pas tout ou partie de ces
nouveaux traités
[Musique]